you represent us confronting this
disease and if that curve flattens
that's definitely good news dr. Jon
LaPook thank you very much
overseas the wife of Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau tested positive
for the corona virus I should say just
north not overseas so Sophie Trudeau is
said to be feeling well the Prime
Minister himself is not showing symptoms
but the two will remain in isolation for
the next two weeks
Sophie had just returned from London
overseas and Ian Lee is in London with
how the British government is changing
its approach to fighting this virus
virus it's unclear at mrs. Trudeau
contracted the virus while she was here
in London the UK has seen a sharp rise
in cases with more than 600 confirmed
but health experts believe the actual
number could be closer to 10,000 this is
the worst public health crisis for a
generation British Prime Minister Boris
Johnson warned the worst is yet to come
I must level with you level with the the
British public more families many more
families are going to lose loved ones
before their time health experts predict
the UK is four weeks from the infection
levels of Italy in that country the
death toll has hit more than 1,000
facing a shortage of hospital beds
doctors are being forced to prioritize
younger patients with a higher survival
rate a team of Chinese medical experts
arrived in Rome overnight bringing their
experience in dealing with the outbreak
meanwhile there is confusion at airports
across Europe after President Trump
instituted a travel ban when we woke up
and actually spent forty two hundred
dollars to rebook flights and then got
to the airport and found out that it
wasn't really applicable to u.s.
citizens but from Asia comes the promise
of an end in sight after months of being
overwhelmed empty hospital beds can now
be seen in China the country posted
another record low for new cases at just
8 while more than 64 thousand people
have been released from the hospital
even South Korea is showing signs of
improvement after achieving the
milestone of more recoveries than new
infections while down under Tom Hanks
and wife Rita Wilson seem in good
spirits after contracting the
iris during their quarantine he told
fans on Instagram they're taking it one
day at a time there's really been a
dealer's choice of responses to the
pandemic here in Europe France Belgium
Ireland and Portugal have decided to
shut down schools and cancel large
events meanwhile here in the UK they're
asking people